schooling hitchcock are just looking at
each other i'm a little worried they're
not gonna be able to you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
okay where'd it go
oh my god they're in a penis upon 69.
[Music]
uh-oh guys we have a major problem here
no garlic bread okay we need to stay
calm let's think the garlic bread needs
to go in the toaster oven with eight
minutes left on the lasagna maybe we
could run down to the corner store and
make it in time that just gives us 12
minutes to go to a place and come back
mama maglione we have to go now okay
well good luck with that weirdos all
right so there's hitchcock and there's
an old hooker yeah
come on guys that happened four years
ago that's the best part she comes back
takes the wallet and here she goes oh
someone
has been painting weiners on squad cars
and apparently they won't stop until
there's a penis drone on every cop car
in brooklyn oh that's what he's been
drawing
but what are those two little round
things at the bottom it's the butt
the butt can you believe this scully
looks like we're the only responsible
people who show up on time anymore and
they're always calling us lazy but where
are they now i don't see them they're
not here but you know who is hitchcock
and scully the oafs the bozos the idiots
what are you doing here the building's
being fumigated there were so many
emails there were we didn't
lightweight that's your takeaway well
how do you even know he's in a bad mood
i mean it's impossible to read that guy
this is the most incompetent worthless
report i have ever read in my life get
your act together or so help me god you
won't live to see retirement
it's like what's that guy thinking you
know
hitchcock boy needs you to fill out a
lineup oh great i'll take my shirt off
no one asked you to take your shirt off
stop volunteering to take your shirt off
i can't hear you shirt's over my ears
what the hell is going on hitchcock and
skully saved the day no you plugged 10
fax machines into one outlet and caused
a fire but i pointed to the fire
extinguisher and was like the fire
extinguisher is over there you point at
the toaster oven all right let's get
started
scully where are you on digitizing the
old case files as of yesterday i'm
officially one percent done
why are you smiling that's nothing oh
there's thousands of cases and for each
one i have to fill out 200 little box
thingies on 50 different screens at
least you get to sit on your butt all
day that's actually the worst part
my doctor said i have an anal canyon
there's a drugstore four blocks away i'm
on it
oh no
scully traveling four blocks
that could take weeks
ooh detectives our monthly crime
statistics are due i want all paperwork
on your closed cases by tomorrow scully
you can just write i didn't close any on
a piece of paper you got it
i can read him and if anyone can figure
out what's bothering him it's me he and
i are exactly the same
except that i'm younger cuban female
single and straight captain holt's not
gay
come old's gay seriously men just retire
go for hitch it's god damn it i meant to
call peralta we're in the middle of a
crisis oh no is it the lasagna the what
don't play dumb with me raymond what's
wrong with the lasagna i have no idea
what you're talking about what is it
what's wrong with lasagna isn't bubbling
over he won't tell me captain give us
the damned information is it bubbling
over i don't have time for these
shenanigans
what's the problem he wouldn't say oh no
then it must be bad call jake he'll tell
us the truth
his car give it to us
what's going on um just searching the
first floor searching the first floor
why is the lasagna on the first floor
why's the lasagna on the first floor
what what are you talking about the
lasagna is fine oh thank god he says
it's fine oh you're saying jakey i love
you okay holt's texting me love you too
hey scully
yeah you want this collar paperwork's
all done and it's perfect the pedowski
kit are you kidding i just gave my lunch
okay it's not our jurisdiction we're
solving this would you like me to file
that pre-check just ask for the donut
scully have the doughnut please yes
thanks guys i think i put my gun in one
of these boxes and i don't know which
i found my gun
it was in my holster my holster's on my
butt
scully hey jake she's been alive forever
how'd you used to cure hangovers oh i
didn't drink i was however extremely
into cocaine for most of 1986. i got to
tell you the truth it's got kaity the
truth you and me man we're gonna be
co-captains but first i'm taking you to
japan
i'm already packed
still don't feel anything awesome i wish
i had nerve damage twist my words all
you want okay i'm winning this bet what
bet what are you guys talking about
seriously
the bet they've been keeping score all
year it comes up all the time what are
you doing all day nothing why you want
to hang out
got it
what
time check five minutes 10 seconds it's
over don't say that we'll never get the
garlic bread toast in a time we can and
we will oh we'll set the oven to 500 are
you insane it'll burn we'll wrap it in
foil the foil will stick to the cheese
it's a risk we'll have to take
look what i found french rice what
no it's hitchcock where would i have
found french fries in a weed farm
the vulture is coming we need more time
someone do something i got it
okay hey can i get your file on that
atlantic i have a new drug ring sarge
gave me and scully the case what
yo
why did you do that i i know i deserved
it but why my first question is
why are the two of you doing this
self-evaluation together scully doesn't
handle pressure well
not to brag
but scully and i have a combined total
of 14 arrests
would have been 20 but well i got 14.
that's not enough arrests well no one
asked you
it's a self-evaluation come on scully
hey i said put your guns down and get
your hands in the air the bread it's
gonna burn guys do what he says i'll buy
you all the garlic bread you want we're
gonna hold you to that sarge
dinner scully i want you to do nothing
just stand next to me and say yes sarge
okay sarge come on man
[Music]
and the rest was history i've been
planning this for three months you've
all been given a specific role and a
code name rosa you're the dagger sarge
the hammer amy the hall monitor yeah
suck it scully and hitchcock i'm just
gonna call you your real name so you
don't get confused smart what
we're sorry that we missed your party
well don't worry about it you you all
had stuff to do yes the capital of
ecuador is quito oh anyway
happy birthday from all of us thanks
guys you're you're the best everybody's
kelly
i can't believe it the fake birthday
work
you're a genius we're both geniuses
thump jack that was my thumbtack
[Music]
what is wrong with our internet i like
to back up my data every 15 minutes and
it's taking 17 minutes per backup i'm in
a data backup deficit we are in the same
boat i've been trying to load this video
all day you're watching videos doing
work i told him to do it sir it's case
related turtle hump's computer mouse
yeah the turtle is the name of a local
pervert we are
chasing
come on hitchcock get it together
those threatening phone calls were being
made to tim orsk of timo's limos it's
interesting this horse guy's name keeps
cropping up in this case because he's
the victim
you know he's the guy whose window was
smashed with this rock
okay it's being extorted for ten
thousand dollars sure but what do they
want from me
ten thousand dollars i just said that
we're trying to figure out who's doing
the threatening wait i have a theory i
think
limousine and magazine come from the
same word just focus
i'm sorry for snapping i interviewed
orsk
there it is again oh you're useless hey
jakey the place on the corner is serving
lemonade and you get to keep the jar
it's pretty cool
yes
that's very cool scully
will you excuse me just one moment oh
sure guys guys guys
scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that no
i called you in here to change your
lives for you see a mere five minutes
ago hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in oh an identical
mason jar oh this isn't gonna end well
there are two possible outcomes and
we're gonna bet on which one happens
first so will hitchcock put fish food in
scully's lemonade or will skully drink
hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
hitchcock just drank his own fish what
you